Ugh!  I hate Halloween.
All the mortal basics come out.
Cool party.
We should take shots.
Mmm.  I don't see any alcohol.
That's fine.  I brought Pumpkin Spice Vodka.
Ah.  What an invention.
I know.  It's like which guys are real vampires and which ones can I suck the life out of tonight?
Don't make me do all the work.
Do you think Victor will show up?
Girl, you murder-suicided with him 200 years ago
it's time to move on.
Ok that's it!  Let's get drunk.
A Bloody Mary for me please.
Actually two Bloody Marys.
Can you make that 3 Bloody Marys?
*screams*
Get the fuck out of here Bloody Mary!
It's not always about her, you know?
*screams*
Ugh, drama queen.
Shut the fuck up!
Thank you.
You're welcome.
*growls*
I love you guys so much!
I would kill you both if you weren't already dead.
Lets be friends forever.  Like, literally forever.
Hi.
You got any Goblin in you?
No.
You want some?
You sure?
No!
Hey, I dig your look.
I used to work at Hot Topic so I get it.
Boy, I would eat you alive.
Is that a threat?  Or a promise?
Both.
*hissing*
He's not worth it.
Fine.
Holy Hitler, it's Victor!
Hey hot lips!  How are you doing baby?
Hi!
*sobbing*
It's like a bunny!?  Really?
This just goes to show you he can't handle a complex undead woman!
Yeah you deserve a real man.  Like a doctor, or a werewolf, or a werewolf doctor.
*thudding*
Occupied!
Fuck forever.  My last victim wanted me to torture him for forever
but after 90 years it just got boring.
Yeah it's not like our parent's generation where you had to be undead with the same person for all of eternity.
Yeah, being the same soul sucker forever seems like it's just soul sucking.
*thudding*
Occupied!
Okay let's go back out there.  You look super hot and really transparent in that dress.
Really?  I've been trying to only possess vegans lately.
It's working.  You look great.
*thudding*
Occupied!
I can't believe I walked through the wall with Victor watching.
So embarrassing.
Well we still showed him, didn't we?
Is anyone going to eat the ears?
They're all yours.
I feel guilty breaking the vegan diet.
It's cheat day bitch!
Ahahahahaha!
We killed that lady.
Ahahaha, yeah.